où
[Musique]
je
bon
c'est au départ
c'était pour la place est bien partout
la presse le prince qui ont déjà été
initiés
aujourd'hui c'est la fin des presque
tout le monde passe et ça c'est vraiment
bizarre au marché
[Musique]
je séchais
si j'ai la pluie les deux principaux
moments lorsque j'étais encore j'avais
une et c est ce que huit à neuf ans
maman me préoccuper en disant de ne pas
aller me balader mais il recommande m a
d'abord appris à qui sait les deux
lignes ici
oh
ceux qui ont été formés ont passé ont
lâché les commandes ils ont donné aux
tâcherons super nes a comme ça à des
mondes qu'ils ont appris une ou deux
choses et ils ont tourné le dos sont
concentrés dans le commerce
qui est cet original d il faut que l'on
soit auprès des artisans j'ai bien dit
des artisans
professionnels qui exercent encore le
métier pourquoi parce que de nos joues
des artisans sont transformés en
promettant d'où le danger de cette
étoffe à disparaît
[Musique]